what up everybody i'm maddie madison and
i'm benny blanco and we're guest
correspondents with wired
[Music]
and today we're testing and reviewing
kitchen gadgets
wait
can we get the first gadget
corn's not a gadget this thing oh chef
and popcorn
easily remove corn from the cob in one
quick twist and pushing motion
wait there's more it's durable stainless
steel blades after they strip kernels in
seconds you just speak the word like
like
you just make it say don't make fun of
my cadence yeah i'm making fun my
cadence is exactly how i talk price 7.99
i bought this as i grow my own corn
yay for you and every year i'm pushed
for space in the freezer so i figured
stripping the corn first would help
doing it with the knife is laborous yeah
it's so difficult and hardly worth the
effort so i tried this
nystrom this gets stuck halfway through
once the cob makes it through my hand
holding the tool would shoot forward and
slam into the bolster and form flying
one star
how do you know what to do wait
oh this is awesome
dude this is great that's perfect how do
you deal with it you twist it
you're still going like this yeah oh
this thing's great dude it's amazing
how did you do it it's so fast though i
have strong hands and shoulders i do see
what
mick nice
i get a little bit everywhere my arm is
so tired why don't you just cut it off
like how you do real no you want to just
turn it like this and then you bought
them too wow
why don't we just cut it like real corn
it's a gadget oh gadgets need to exist
is the greatest tool
i've ever used in my life
you smell like gasoline
this is 100 the best thing i've ever
seen it's easily that's a five star wait
it's five we don't even know what the
next gadgets are it doesn't matter it's
just this is an individual product this
is the hardest thing i've ever done i
think they're just like not really sound
in the head wins grammys can't twist a
piece of corn can i get the next gadget
please
oh is this a therma mix you can make
beef stroganoff you can make
stuffed squid
how do you make stuff how does that make
does it have hands inside yep it's got
hands
you can't even open it
where's the hands there's hands in there
no there's blades they'll cut your hands
off yeah then you get hands malto by uh
cook a pal this cooking pal has 10
appliances and 10 appliances in one yep
it's got a food processor scale steamer
kneading machine
yogurt
slow cooker
yogurt maker yeah declutterer for your
countertop space during cooking wi-fi
bluetooth capabilities you can check
your doji coins 999 is 1.99
all-in-one cooking robot amazing i've
been using other brands similar to this
product for years this new
mo
they need a better name that's crazy
name's trash my name is trash no extra
costs or guided cookbook recipe i'll
include it and that was five stars i
opened the lid to find a soupy lukewarm
mess of noodles while garlic and heavy
cream it was terrible raw garlic
imparted a strange sweetness to the dish
that's impossible and though it looked
okay it didn't taste very good so that
one was three stars they just said it's
a liquid lukewarm mess and then they
said it looked good i have all of my
ingredients here it's a really great
melange of ingredients that we're just
going to create a bechamel you know it's
a foundation of many kind of cooking
things like gravies and sauces so add
flour add flour how much flour ben okay
you add 1.7 ounces of flour just pour it
in and i'll tell you when it's ready
[Music]
i'll add the butter 1.5 ounces
no too much take some out
[Music]
how much
we don't we don't even have enough milk
[Music]
no perfect perfect perfect okay now no i
don't drink milk that's why you have
weak bones we need 0.5 teaspoons of salt
we need one pinch of pepper now we need
to start you need the nutmeg no it
doesn't say put nut back in
okay perfect yeah yeah where you go
where are you okay this one's so much
harder than that is it start
now we just wait seven minutes
add nutmeg and chopped gruyere here open
it up no no don't there's nothing in
this it's the same that's in there it's
fine
okay start
[Music]
that's ready okay who's got a ball you
get this thousand dollar thing over here
and you just cover it up
don't worry
that's nice
now drink it
how's it taste
that's so salty
it's salty
if you follow the recipe it'd probably
be a little bit different but you know
smell that
this one's great five or five stars ten
world's greatest highly recommend you're
seeing it here first that's great that
was that tastes good
no lie a regular person doesn't need
that but also if you have a thousand
dollars
to spend on that you don't give a
about anything so
next gadget please
it looks like i have a telescope
no okay it's a sushi bazooka ninja kit
this 14-piece sushi main kit is perfect
for all sushi lovers of all levels with
its simple to make do-it-yourself kit
showcase your inner sushi ninja and
create masterpieces that no one has
dared
16.99 that's the price i can get behind
it's like a pack of smokes you need
batteries andrew this sushi bazooka is
amazing no issues i'm not sure why
others reported it's breaking the
instructions are easy to understand the
avocado slicer works like a dream five
stars what it comes with the bazooka
that is the you're holding the bazooka
but this is just broke this is i don't
understand why this is even on it
because it doesn't
this is a terrible sushi maker it won't
even stay together long enough to make
anything there's so much stuff on our
thing i can't even see yeah there's like
caked on flour it's all in pieces and
you have to figure everything out and it
won't stay together one star
okay so how do you even try ah you
literally just this thing's a knife no
it's not yes it is so we have cooked
rice this is for the most basic losers
ever if you order california roll you're
a loser
wait what about the avocado the slicer
comes with the bazooka yeah it slices it
easy
[Music]
look at your shirt
this one's broken
[Music]
it does bazooka pretty good
but i don't understand why you need this
if you have the roller
this is the best invention ever
oh yeah this is glow
it's like doing everything twice yeah
you just take the rice and you put it on
top of the thing without this this is
like you're doing it twice yeah really
nice
the bazooka does get it out
yeah it looks great yeah sushi is great
besides ignoring being kind
and everything else
is really good
yeah 10 stars yeah this is a 10 out of
10. you saw it
you saw the magic
hey can we have the next gadget
oh perfect
[Applause]
a pasta extruder i think that ice cream
maker for sure ice cream maker i don't
know you see the front let me look at it
phillip pasta noodle maker plus the
phillips pasta noodle maker plus creates
fresh homemade pasta noodles any day of
the week
it doesn't discriminate in 10 minutes
in 10 minutes just add your flower press
the button
machine automatically mixes knees and
extrudes in one go making pull process
easy and efficient 300
good review bought a second one this
pasta maker was recommended by a friend
she told me how easy it was to use the
pasta maker and it came out great i
bought one for my daughter and my
son-in-law for christmas that's like 900
bucks carol brandon back off machine i
thought it had an auto wave function duh
doesn't but it does not i wonder if i
got a knock off machine by mistake we've
tried to make a pasta three times so far
it's been very difficult three stars for
being so mad she still gave it three
stars doesn't seem that bad let's make a
cat spaghetti
let's make some pasta flower
no no no first mix it up
it's good it's good you can see
perfect
[Music]
clay
oh it's like a laundry detergent
wait
spaghetti's coming for dinner
and now we have to wait for it it's done
see no it just it's fine
e1 i think that means error do you like
spaghetti betty
shut up
okay it stopped now oh no no
what are these knobs for okay guys so
as you can see
it extrudes all the pasta really well
no yeah it's coming great this is how
you're supposed to do it no no it's
perfect here take it out we just need
more flour
there now do it
you're still sushi everywhere it says e1
it says e1
if you have a michelin restaurant
if you have any type of restaurant ever
this is what's in the kitchen the first
pasta ever made in italy was on the
philips extruder here
easily this is a five out of five
oh this is oh that's nice
what is that it's almost like a ramen
noodle this is beautiful
if we would have just taken our time and
not rat food pasta you just you don't
want it to be sticky you want it to be
each strand to be really nice and dry
this is great individual
you don't want to be able to pull up
your parts easily final gadget please
[Music]
egg top topper shell oh
so this is for quail eggs is that for
quail eggs like smaller eggs small lips
egg topper eggshell cutter quickly open
eggs without dirty hands the egg topper
is easy to use just align the cup wait
just wait just read it no there's so
much stuff with your eyes just align the
cup on egg top pull out the hammer and
let it go 9.99 i love this eggshell
cutter because it's two sizes and it's
so easy to make the holes yeah crack and
eggs been just a big dilemma the entire
existence of human race i also love that
one it's not too big okay next perfect
size one star does not work reviews are
fake the eggshell does not cut clean
debris will get in food
a lot of debris nine dollars okay so
what do you do
no no i think you put it down no no no
are you one trying i've been doing
everything
okay you're right
i don't have an ipad you ready
yeah
oh perf
am i doing it yeah you did it it's done
oh there you go see perfect look you
don't even dirty your hands so perfect
guys you're supposed to do this on eggs
that have already been cooked this
this would not be for a raw egg no it's
perfect you brought raw eggs
are you oh is this a joke what is this
like you're trying to fuss up
[Music]
five hours five out of five
read his invention the spring can suck
it the fork get out of here your hands
off this thing can open eggs better
than anything
uh
man how many we did five and that's all
five gadgets i'm matt matheson thank you
for having me
i'm sorry blanco why do you always yell
it works